let's go next to our caller from the 6-8
to area code caller from 6-8 to
introduce yourself tell us where you're
calling from what's on your mind today
hi um this is Thomas and I'm from Dallas
Texas what's on your mind today I have a
question about Trump saying that he
wants to use an executive order to
effectively get rid of the 14th
amendment I just have some points on
that it's just basically the 14th
amendment makes it so that it is
effectively legalizing birthright
citizenship I mean I'm not really sure
like how you would define if you were an
American citizen like what do you have
to be born from the American vagina or
something okay go on it's just like it
says you have to be born if you're born
in this land then you're effectively an
American citizen and a citizen of the
state that you're in
and I watched TYT talk about birthright
citizenship and how if you get rid of it
and you're basically disenfranchising
millions of potential voters or and it
was also funny when they mentioned how
like Trent's older children could be
affected by a TIA since they weren't but
it was effectively like a birthright
citizens well yes yes or no I mean yes I
understand that that their mother was
naturalized but I mean their their
father was an American citizen so I get
that I think it's sort of one of those
arguments that's that's sort of meme
worthy but I don't I don't know how good
of an argument it is did you have a
question or a particular thing you
wanted me to comment on because I did do
a commentary earlier in the week about
that birthright citizenship thing what
was there something in specific you
wanted to ask about
if Trump actually goes ahead and just
like signs an executive order what do
you think would happen from that what
would would people just with the entire
body of Congress just say no or I mean
would actually be legal or whatever
because what I've read oh you there's
like a giant from whatever assets to get
an amendment room yes there is from what
I've read the consensus of the legal
community is that it would not fly
there are a few conservative legal
opinions that say that you can without
changing the 14th amendment you can
dictate policy via executive order in
such a way that would allow you to do
that but then the next president would
immediately be able to change it if they
wanted my you know we're still learning
about the legal aspects of it I think it
would be an uphill battle and I don't I
don't think ultimately he would be able
to do it via executive order thank you
so much for the call really appreciate
it